together and Jack I'm gonna run that
wait now connect to run down and that's
like into the campaign manager you make
your party once you're like in the
launch screen I'll sit you guys party
and what am i injecting no you're good
that's just how you get in don't worry I
got you bro so they invite the fit bum
bum I love intros like that I love [ __ ]
that's like completely off-putting crazy
nonsense that makes no sense it means
nothing
no it's immersive right off the bat like
it's like it takes like be opening up a
game out of it it's more just like
you're in the experience right out right
out of the gate
in your in your tool in your third slot
there are two two different types of
centuries a mind deployer a bio tracker
and seafoam launchers seafoam slows them
down right yeah two people with seafoam
and to people with centuries I'll be a
foam boy a foam it up yes century man no
century above what do you want to do
mark uh wait would be a foam boy I'll be
a foam boy sea foam oh yeah yeah why is
my character like going insane yeah
you're like beat your own head I am into
this like a million percent this is so
up my alley mark can you calm down no
all right white loud hell yeah
oh hi oh this is like [ __ ] halo ODST
oh god this is so cool whoa
y'all ready to drop tilted Oh baby
we going to react to light and sound
eerie sounds yep
unintelligible serene yeah that's fine
that's fine that's worth putting in
there yeah okay oh what's happening I'm
scared stay still oh we didn't the beta
and the beta you like Exorcist freaked
out there at the end
wait this isn't beta I thought it was
still early after there was a whole
separate download for this check out my
hammer
okay right front humors are not melee
each other you can shoot each other also
it's a charge it's a charge melee so
fully charge had enemies oh hell yeah
I'm gonna make biscuits with this in the
top right you'll see how much ammo you
have this is spooky
I'm already dropped in with half a mo
anyway yeah so there's gonna be
basically enemies and they are like
asleep until we wake them up and so you
have to sort of crouched and spot them
good job what's [ __ ] it do that we
could run pretty much melee only for
this first part you just and they react
to your light to so quite careful with
your light being off and on and Hyrum
you here I'm global a little bit how
does the map oh wait oh I can draw him
at higher audio oh yeah you can draw on
the map how do i oh there we go okay
well yeah that didn't take long
basically we need to explore and find a
key card to access a specific area to
access in the top left it says find
hydro stasis unit hsu 500 and retrieve
DNA core sample okay do that and then
get to the extract and get the [ __ ] out
so they're a little like computer
terminals okay
you look on the map at the little orange
box on the bottom left over here I think
that's just like a toolbox or something
but there will be stuff on that on the
map like that and some of them will be
computers and you have to actually type
commands into the computers oh we share
a map damn it's yeah
it's complicated and no swilling - I'm
willing to learn
I'm so annoyed we so don't want to fight
things is that would be my number one
thing boss
you don't want to fight things matter
I'm upstairs oh wow oh you have you hack
in that market yeah I'm hacking it yeah
baby I hacked it up I've got an ammo
pack grab that yeah you can carry it so
you can Remo people okay does it have
some Iturbe usage yeah it has like four
uses I think okay Oh glow sticks they're
good right cuz they don't react to those
yeah glow sticks or chill so basically
we have to pick a door and just explore
we don't have any info right now we need
to find a computer and we need to get
start gathering information need on so
we want to gather up here there's a tool
refill pack right here oh yeah that [ __ ]
I can't damn oh you can only carry one
thingy I got it there we go so we've
entirely reached the extent of my like
knowledge about this oh we just got
explored ow and see what the [ __ ]
happens where are you boys this which
door we pick over here by the road just
so I'm ready when that door opens we're
not running in guns blazing it is quiet
gonna be asleep we do not wake them up I
not even like I will not have an
outburst here is very are they in the
darkness hey you will see them when they
get agitated they will start to like
glow and glorg lyrtle oh this is okay no
I know this level okay I know this level
okay okay I know this okay okay so this
door the handle says alarm detected yeah
so when we when we open it it's gonna
wake a bunch of them up oh you don't
want that well we have to go that way
but I've learned a little pro tip later
in the level this door over here I hear
you I hear many noises yeah they're for
these doors we do we don't want them to
be destroyed
the enemy is when they get attracted
will destroy doors so let's open these
up even though we don't need to be in
here right now
hound like no no no it'll be fine it'll
be fine
ready this is awesome okay so also if
you want to look into darkness but you
don't want to disturb them if you just
flash your light it won't generally like
wake them all the way up feel like that
would be more noticing yeah I feel like
that's annoying
it's a duration thing not like a not
like an attention thing so this is
another alarm one we want to leave this
bad boy I think this is our final room
that we get to to get a new sample we
need two key card for that one yeah so
we need to get the key card for that
door so we're gonna open this one there
might be bad guys in here mmm
what door right here clears I'm scared
Killam is so the yeah they'll be asleep
oh you won't
that's what commuter don't use it yet
everyone come look this is this is a bad
boy on the floor you don't move she's
throbbing throbbing is bad that's these
are like the base enemies which is just
chill it's fine it's fine go back to
sleep give it a little sleep Hammer
story with your hammer I'm just gonna
hit him with it hit him hit him with Lou
ups with a fully charged melee there
might be more continue to chill now
that's like the witch protocol and left
for dead but for every enemy he goes
like that worse some of them move some
of them are terrifying oh so they're not
all like that leads back to where we
were so we're chill but come over here
this computer thing is what we need so
you have to use these computer terminals
and you have to type in commands someone
access it and type find space hsu
underscore 500 what's this not
recognized as a commend oh maybe I need
to run something
I'll try I see I've never actually done
this are these noises things oh it's
just uh it's just spoopy I just hear
like creaking and footsteps in the
distance I'm just putting it out in the
universe you know what I mean at least
here that's not a thing we have to worry
about are you sure Hsu 500 you got owe
you 500 wait this zone 15 over here
location zone 52 ping out of range get
the zone 52 to find the item zone 52 is
the one that needed a keycard also I can
see something through this little window
oh wait does it say what key car we need
huh what does the door white white why
do you why 79 ping that white seven
seven nine okay yeah pea brains query
and keen white 779 normal location zone
50:50 keycard
bring the keycard back here okay c-can I
ever see zone 50 on the map I don't
think we've found that do we have to
discover it we have it's gotta be
through 49 B then I mean though there's
a lot of 49 B well here's so here's on
49 m should we explore this before we go
in through the alarmed or maybe why not
yeah do you ready my bros yeah I'm ready
for the terror so our our light has to
be like on them right to agitate that
it's just in the area they'll
immediately start throbbing and clicking
if you hit them so like if you if you
think you're in trouble just lights off
crouch don't move Phil they'll calm down
a little bit okay yeah this is not
fruitful there this is just a little
side playing with with loot in it I
think no so now we have to do the alarm
I have this trap for this I have this
Drive for this I think it'll work
probably so your turrets will only shoot
at enemies but turret bullets will hurt
you okay in front of them I'm gonna put
mine like here are we pointing into the
zone 49c pointing it this way so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna come
inside here close close this door and
then trigger the alarm because they'll
come from this way so
put your turret in here covering the
doorway and fire yeah you should put my
wall so I don't want to shoot at us
right I want to shoot across the door
shoot out the door because we need a
safe place to stand so where do you hurt
my leg up here like you're firing at the
door so you can cover the whole mouth of
the door
but we have safe places to stand in fire
and this is the only direction they'll
come from yes so there's they won't come
through the alarm door and I don't think
they'll come through this because this
is blocked off so they'll come through
this door we have covered with the
turrets yeah so who wants to oh we have
to do a thing for the alarm [ __ ] okay so
there's gonna be when I trigger the
alarm thing if there's like a hack
basically there will be little circles
that appear on the ground we all have to
stand in them and then Oh though the
gimmick is you have to fill all the
circles so there at some way there'll be
four circles but anyway we're about to
do this so don't shoot each other don't
get in the way the turrets and have fun
I hope we live oh okay okay yeah stand
in my security circle oh come in is that
it yes so they're trying to breach the
door right now okay the circle is one
more circle over here that is a big one
you were right about that that is a big
do headshots do more guides yes he said
he did is he
holy [ __ ] he's not dead so if you shoot
their heads off and they're on the
ground they still hurt you if there's
okay good good job gamers Bagan booster
oh god I'm at 30% health who's got a med
pack
how do I you come on come over to me and
Amy not Hale not me not me what are you
doing sorry
kill me daddy okay was that like a baby
level wave yes far as the craziest waves
go that was trashed here there's nothing
oh good good great yeah that's that's
yeah so some of them shoot stuff out of
their brain holes and you gotta watch
out for that [ __ ] cuz ouch okay so now
the alarm door should be open I'm just
closing those for like safety but yeah
lights off
Mele is out everyone shut the [ __ ] up
let's let's be cautious Jesus Christ all
right let's do this
this is and we go left or straight we
need to explore everywhere so Josh ously
cautiously explore should we open the
small door up here so we hold off on
that one let's see what's up in this
room before we get too involved in
anything else I [ __ ] love this game
already what our squishers sounds sounds
or bad squishy sounds squishy organic
sounds is this big clunky in the
distance sounds it's just the level
ambiance is fine squishy terrifying
sounds of aliveness not good news okay
shooter terminal over here Harshad hi
you seen anything no okay me neither
some kind of a dog here I see it's not
there's nothing down to this pit yeah
there's a door over here leads no I
don't know door 682 should I open it
let's do that together I think this room
is clear so let's do the computer
terminal in here okay okay you got it
you and see if anything doesn't remember
what the key number was seven seven nine
yeah key whites of night
so we cleared this so we're good to walk
around with flashlights right yeah this
room is fine the flashlights on do
whatever you want that pain was the key
you guys hear that [ __ ] I kind of do it
again hanging up hanging again would try
and figure out what the door it's
through or if it's in this room
oh right yet yeah dude east-southeast I
think it's over here kind of her I own
it
uh yeah over over were you are America I
think it's through this door there's
like it's above me here I don't hear it
over here by where Mark was I hear it
was south way south it was loud it was
loud let me compare oh right well you're
right you're right you're right you're
right maybe it can be in our room it
could be in our room Oh up here it's
back here that's right I'm going Lari
close to right here yeah I think it's
like over in this area
do you see where I'm marking on the map
yeah I think if we go through this door
where I'm yeah I agree I think that's
the right way
yeah so I'll come to that door yep over
where you guys is that that's such a
cool mechanic you just gotta listen for
it it's so simple
yesterday for another bridge yeah baby
you know good this game won't be [ __ ]
impossible if you didn't have discord
yeah I know
yeah how would you play this with
randoms all right
ping the heat it's not a big room
there's a locker here it may also just
be like sitting on a shelf it may also
be further through this other door I
think it's through this next door yeah
we were all being pulled this is a
resource an ammo pack here I'll take the
pack just because I'm holding it we can
already we can take the pack and spend
it yeah who needs salmon oh I'm at 44%
you can see each other's percentages if
you look at each other - okay
right do you want Bob you want em oh
yeah give me one mo I guess one uh Shawn
Ewan and Shawn I guess yeah okay and
then take the other mo pack market mole
key door opening folks lights off let's
do this mark how do I use it on myself
just get away from everyone and then
holding and it should self apply ha
there we go okay and go through this
locker down here oh yeah that's a door
that opens oh are you hacking that bad
boy yes you could do it you want me to
go back and ping if you want to that
might be helpful all right I'll go I
remember this map I think this room is
like the last room in this stretch in
the state key key key you got their
money key white 7/7 Ives okay guys hey
this is easy guys
screams OH so yes I'm everywhere weekend
is cool so we can go back to the door
and do the key the key we're gonna need
seafoam we're gonna need we're gonna
it's gonna be a gonna be a heck of a
thing it's gonna be it's gonna be like
how we held this room it's gonna be
crazier than that the key doors suck
this is going to suck where was the key
door to say it's in here by me there
were so few enemies in the important
areas yeah we've only had one room with
an enemy so for today I encountered so
much [ __ ] when I should know it's
the first time should we do or wait so
we need to set up like we did before
okay yeah it's door quick foam broke
okay there is more to your right on that
wall what was that oh god there's a
century okay sounded like screaming so
when when [ __ ] starts going down we want
to see foam up this area right here okay
you want to see sea foam this doorway
okay you have to like hold it down and
it'll sort of burst it explains the
mechanics of what sea foam does because
it's just for those who don't know in
chess globs and it slows them down so
you want to slow them in the turret rate
I want to get it on the way floor or
right after shooting at the floor you
shoot it before anything happens as
we're about to trigger [ __ ] okay shoot
floor and it lasts for like a couple
minutes okay
is it like you hold it down to shoot
looks look man I don't want to get if
you just tap it you like won't squirt
anything out where will barely shoot at
all this is an actual holding there's
like a full charge blast and it all when
you release it'll be like
so ain't like spread it around you know
and shoot it all at one spot okay all
right so I got an edge of the gun a
little bit yeah okay I got it now now I
understand how this functions but one
one foamer man if you want to hit that
okay we're right now and then let's
trigger this [ __ ] you got it Shawn you
were born for this I'm just gonna watch
how it works just said I'm gonna I'm
gonna watch you foam
staying interesting yep okay charge it
up and then let go yeah yeah that's
probably it go for it that all right
door door door door
beard die it's fine it's going okay okay
okay okay easy okay good luck gamers oh
oh oh dick dicks out falling line I got
my line wait wait who's not in the line
oh they're here with me Jesus Christ
okay oh hey my god this is [ __ ] scary
follow the line we have to do it again
and fight keep doing it keep doing okay
okay okay I'm in I'm in a line here
I hope this security gun doesn't shoot
me we got it we got it we got it
next one next one oh no we didn't get it
we didn't get it to my circle beaten out
of mine the circle is Mickey may have
bit me
okay I'm going for a far one though
there's people here this one no someone
else got that one oh god where is it I
missed it was I on it I don't know Oh
God what are you shooting at me
holy crap there's so many okay yeah I'm
down
okay calm down
[ __ ] these okay the run right at the
door got it Wow I didn't seem to win out
we need to win the fight don't worry too
much about the circles if weights okay
okay okay
[ __ ] your guide the one I was just
getting lit up
can we get weighed up now oh there's
still more all right I'm gonna try and
get weighed up okay I'm about to go down
but I'll keep shooting who use it myself
oh wow oh wow there's so many down
we never got past the keycard part on
Martha no yeah we were going to security
stay on the one side there were so many
things by me and I would just put and
fight them all off oh my god there's so
many my heart's pounding
yeah so that's about how that went my
first time I guess all right I'm going I
might be pistols pistols out the turrets
outside the door and then close the door
to buy time sense that does make sense
did the turrets get destroyed I think
that was asked but I think the turtle
dolls they're fine and just run out of
ammo okay God you gotta get mad for them
too yeah but all right sorry I gotta go
that was really what happened to us at
the end we all got boner so damn we go
boys all right I think we did pretty
good I think those okay and now we now
we know we can blast through that again
we can we can run sprinting screaming at
the top of our lungs wait is it the same
orientation or is it randomized so the
where things are and what loot spawns is
all different but it's the same like map
I just love what the game starts you at
59% ammo
48%
he'd come in fully stacked good tits out
eyes eyes in balls
what's up lynched played this there were
other and there were enemies in here
yeah in every room right yeah every roof
had [ __ ] in it blue key six three eight
six two I got it there may be an enemy
in here yeah I thought I saw something
he was here last time yeah I think we're
good Bobby you know the computer thing
you paying someone else should learn it
just so that it's not it says on it even
if you type commands it'll show you you
literally just type ping or query and
then the you have to accurately type
what we're looking for which is thirty
blue key six three eight query blue wait
blue six three eight three eight ok
querying zone fifty to get close enough
ok so well so can you ping it all right
it's a it's just ping out of range
ok we got to get to go onward yesterday
for the big door oh yeah yeah I'm ready
nails chill
so I heard one to the right one to the
left ok yeah oh he's here he's here
where so I just I just like inch my
weight towards him yeah you have to be
pretty close but then just hit him with
one Oh
stand over there just hit him with one
fully charged melee right in the dome
this dome oh this [ __ ] sucks
do I have an indication of when is good
to swing when you feel like you could
hit him with a two-handed hammer Oh Bob
that one's standing up I know so when
you charge it'll stay charged until
you're ready right oh never mind I just
realized that's not true see that one
red flash alright so I guess we just set
up our turret situation oh that's good
that's good that's good that's good
can we close this door all right let me
know it can trigger gamer and bless
let's do some
do some terrifying [ __ ] nerds in the
circle yep I love you guys have a good
game out there I peed myself there's got
to be like a system to like to know
videos in what like circle we gotta like
set up someone's far right
someone's far left and that Latta like
these you're defined to the app - yeah
our door yeah you right
interesting very interesting oh oh Jesus
alright so much easier
Thanks turret can work turret turret
left
I'm at 44 where do you get at 45 the
cool ammo box thing chill chill chill
chill chill chill
so chill chill well I spend it up though
since you go back down now your instant
yeah it's the position they're in is
fine he's not I can see your insights
mister what's going on fine this is fine
looks like you were just like inside mmm
your hammer is like touching his belly
okay yeah there may be a an enemy in
this room that is extra terrifying that
we haven't seen yet why would you just
say that but it is eyes up boys do you
know because the first time I heard it
it's the worst enemy that can be in this
room and talking about if we clear this
room yet are we sure we're clear we are
not clear not corner I think we are I
can't see anything in here cobble bolt
claim won't claim my sir dicks out boys
rusty I'm going down into the paint
remember me as the gamer I was I'm in
the game right about it I found the
terminal should I do some one thing that
[ __ ] you ping the key cute 638 yeah okay
all right all right I think this main
room is clear I think we are chilling
yeah oh that's close heard that I heard
that through this door down by Bob I
think pinging again is that help I think
it's in this I found yeah the key you
[ __ ]
oh hell yeah I was literally in this
random but man what a [ __ ] baby wimpy
ass job what is this [ __ ] okay I'm
supposed to be hard
what is it we were just dancing through
this like it's a meadow full of love are
we clear yeah we're clear shouting at
random ugh this is a security system
door again should we just go to main
door or is it even worth trying this I
mean you want to have some adventures
yeah well it's adventure but I'm gonna
give you guys I'm making an executive
decision I'm just gonna give you a mo
take it he's given us a packed lunch
yeah this is a spot to hold I think you
know do this we want to hold the high
ground
oh wait wait it's not gonna give us
circles that are like entire map across
from each other are they this is a tool
refill pack another tool refill Peck
I've got a memo [ __ ] hell yeah I'm just
gonna open this door I'm I'm oh I'm at
67 so there's two right next to each
other in here here have some foam yeah
chill you guys got it running around at
full speed it stopped moving going for
it I wasn't charged what the [ __ ] he's
dead he's dead cut down he's God nice
bunch of babies just hit me with the I
lost 25 health dude I don't know we had
to synchronize them I thought I would
just like kill him and then the other
one you could kill all their if they're
that close together pisses him off Bob
got me top you off
yeah yes but the good news is there was
nothing in this room yeah worth it one
charge left on that I just like smacking
things dude I can see that I can see I
can see yeah there's there's a no wait
there's a med pack here there's another
door
they said at the start no one picked it
up I thought someone I thought I heard
someone say they picked it up so I
assumed there was that one no we might
as well right adventure right wait what
do we hope to gain from it just a mo
okay in another mentor maybe yeah mo
pack I thought you're at the security
door we got any big boys doesn't look
like it another door boys all right
that's this room ooh what was that that
was juicy that was very juicy I think
that sounds stairs whatever it is this
is clear we don't have any eyes or
whatever it was there's no containers
down here this time all damage okay I
was just bill I feel obliged toward you
I appreciate what about the cabinet what
about the cabinet to the left you can
see technical boy walks around it was
nothing but glow sticks and he stops and
and if you touch the tentacles it alerts
everyone just continue to exist without
us
we have to go yeah I've seen enough hand
tighten over that go that can be in the
main room we have to go through oh
[ __ ] worse let's do this [ __ ] shall
we do the key baby turrets outside
firing the door Mike you want to see
foam foam it up it's just like jerkin it
and then you just you just go you just
goop okay
the order of operations is sea foam
outside the door close the door trigger
the [ __ ] turrets please god save
all right just just so we know also I am
always gonna try to go for the far right
circle that I left I'll go second right
I'll go next to mark yeah okay I'm
actually gonna do the crossfire like
this do we move mud no no I just I would
I want more exposure on stuff as it's
going through the door I guess makes
sense I'm gonna go about to groove let's
do this close the door
trigger that I think I have the key card
actually I'm gonna goop in door here
after you're done so we can do this I'm
gonna goop this way it should I I
thought you were done it's time run run
run run sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry
sorry
okay so me and Bob are left little left
middle left okay all right come on right
all right baby
those are good sounds doors doors
getting spreading all right got it I'm
in it go go go exit good [ __ ] where's
the spread there's the spread oh god no
oh sweet Oh God what is that okay I
think this is far right back Oh God okay
I'm gonna move I'm crossing over good
got in the circles okay it's going
through it once coming through I'm gonna
goof again yeah yeah keep that door
goofed up I think that's dude god who's
hitting me Oh God I'm in middle life Oh
God Circle Circle
Oh God yes something was as something
keeps hitting me what's hitting me they
have raised oh oh god they do all right
so that would say I will cover you I
think we did it I feel like I was shot
crossfire by a turret oh this way thank
you oh wait get your turrets yeah just
get those turrets back I feel like I was
shot Shh lights up calm down just feel
like hammers out hammers I feel like I
was shot is that is that a man it's a
that's a boy maybe a boy or a man huh
whoo go get him
are you an angry boy this one no this
looks like corpses
that's how they get you
wait maybe we should do this door Ramdev
right it was corpses is this the other
side of the room do this is this a
clinical rumor is that somewhere else no
no let's not do that
yeah there's two in there that's fine
that's fine
they don't need us I'm gonna go up okay
I'm on definitely yeah I'll go with Wade
you because we're the right team right
liberals wait why are you rocking with
lights out the whole time well I'm
pretty sure it's clear then I'm pulling
out later on we open I have one more med
pack charge I'm gonna put that on say
one lower than 88 well I got 80 80 even
yeah mark let me put this on you myself
no use on the boom-boom okay I think
we're clear in here I think we're clear
Sean peep that door let's see what's
[Music]
call me Judy mark we need to pop your
cherry all right I got I'll get it I'll
get it ready I'm ready I'm ready
okay okay so we need to synchronize
these [ __ ] then are they right there
just one side or the other one coffee
how about you open it we both charge
they're right there we just no quiet
voice reason in my head say no
immediately open the door let's see what
we're dealing with they won't get us if
you just stand still late lights off -
lights off lights operable thing and
this one there
it's okay let my to recover stand back
don't go into turret shot it's fine what
a bunch of babies they just started
killing our lights were off we were we
were crouched there's a terminal here uh
uh we need that look for Hsu Hsu 949
open up that door see what were people
that's more like how this game started
whenever the beta was out is that from
in that room you guys let me query it
just to make sure this is Z 49z 50 to be
querying Wow that's good that's good in
zone 52 funny this door goes right to
there well let's turn our lights off and
just party this up shall we all right
yeah there's five things in four dudes
what do we do it's fine it is fine fine
sneak attack the wall beautiful you have
to kill them is the other thing we can
sneak around them crouch you psychopath
we are we are no so the two in the back
are far enough back we could kill the
three and then the two okay I'm going
you down to our rights you guys got it
you guys got it okay okay go to sleep
with the bubonic plague on the left
what's with that that's not good it's
fine he's just special you have to stop
moving completely I want to be clear
about this right when things go tits up
which they invariably will what do we do
I'll close the door so Moe is the door
that mark is in run back hold the door I
cannot promise it will close after you
get through the door these are all
pulsating at different different
intervals you just have to not piss them
off too many times
okay I'm going for barnacle Billy here
on the left
oh you're [ __ ] [ __ ] care crash deck
you cannot swing until already I got it
I cannot stress this enough I'm within
range I am with oh oh oh it's fine it's
fine it's fine
don't don't fine it's fine it's fine
it's fine it's okay I was about to swing
I eat I was about to [ __ ] blast so
I'll do you like it the may light thing
do I need to aim for the head
specifically yes yes I'm in the head so
your circle goes smaller when you're
with ease just shush shush shush shush
oh wait mines mines doing a thing yep
just wait as long as you have a small
circle you're ready alright you're
getting the small targeting circle wait
are you still yet not yet it's going to
keep stretching okay okay I've got small
targeting circle I'll start from 5 it'll
be 5 4 charge your things to 1 start
charging when I say start charging and
then we'll release on 3 2 1 murder okay
ready start charging now and 3 2 1
murder beautifully done
beautiful I spot it all great good stuff
I was ready to close the door mark
there's 2 down to the right and we have
these two up here so we still get it
alright ok alright sounds like a job for
you guys who wants to be a murder
partner with me I don't know I
I'm [ __ ] 3 for 3 right now I'm just
saying you two I'll go down with Mark
and take out the other two wait what
what at once I just gotta say the first
time mark tried to do it it got us all
almost killed look look it wasn't my
fault it may have been my fault okay
they're charging now charging wait don't
do it I'm almost there I'm almost there
what do you mean what do you mean what
do you mean what do you mean
oh god oh god it's happening now oh wait
no please I can't find you how are you
got him Oh God kitties are down down
here okay we're dead we're dead
we're dead yeah we're good I took one
small hit but I'm okay okay who's the
furthest one away I don't know what
happened
yeah I saw my dude started turned purple
and I was just I just took him out
before he charged at us yeah there was
actually one there was a third one down
here yeah that's the one that we should
have done oh it's rocker four-way but
it's all good God my heart is honestly
well actually pounding like so tense
okay there's also a room up here
where the computer can I ping this [ __ ]
yeah keep that room I'll peep it let me
real quick okay no one do anything
should I leave this big door shut Bob
the one I'm by okay okay door by me is
Bad News Bears this rooms okay it goes
back to where we came in so we're good
okay yeah I'm gonna ping I'm gonna ping
the HSU okay let's sign next to this so
we can hear I have a feeling it's by the
bad door the Shawn looked in probably no
it's right here it sure is
there's one right inside the door to the
right that's the only one I saw okay
well you could start charging now no no
no no no literally right inside okay
maybe yeah actually that's what happened
last time Bobby was right inside the
door we opened it they just somebody
somebody opened up the door cuz I know
where it is they should be able re all
looking it alright it's all you jack
okay open oh there's two got him got him
nice nice chill chill there's more
there's more chill chill
there's one back right there's one back
right we're back right Russell I'm
looking at it I'm looking at there's one
in the ground I can't see the ball extra
100 full e hard be very careful there I
get this one solo I spy in the far
distance from that one in
you would okay mark I have a plan if I
start running I'll just hit you okay
sounds almost like there's another one
right but that might be the one bob is
going for I think you're correct on that
assumption okay Bob spirits mad as bad
as bad not clear
okay these are still da saw still docile
they're coming up they're coming up okay
here we go
Yahoo ski well I just actually think
shot you Wow I'll fall back fall back
okay Alamo sound like a code first Alamo
that means we run the [ __ ] back God two
more two more three more not clear not
clear at all
I'll let her stay back stay back okay
bait that there range these ones are
ranged once all right so I don't know if
they're gonna come I got him
okay anyone got any heal tool refill
right here yeah there you go thank you
I could use ammo if anybody has it I've
got ammo you want I should start using
my shotguns I've almost got max shotgun
I've got pistol
yeah shotguns dope thank you that's fine
I think we're fine so we're looking for
like the HSU is like a tank or something
it's like a DNA sample so right it's in
this room
that's what sounded like it connected to
this room I'll go I'll go ping okay oh
there's another door down here please
don't be in another door you pinging
pinging now yeah it sounded know it's in
the other door okay close I just coming
back this is stressful si that's awesome
though we survived the key door that's
further than I've ever gotten is the
last time you had a multiplayer horror
games that actually scared you yeah
never fair okay opening it's off lights
on it's off oh this looks like a good
room I like this room this room is fine
there's no Tricky's that's this thing
yeah I'm not hearing anything
wait this is oh wait these are the
things guys this is a chess u310 bases
you throw it's one of these it's what
we're looking for it's like a little
tube I guess it's a person
don't take the DNA core sample set it oh
wait don't wait hang on don't do it well
so it's it should say Hsu whatever the
right number is 949 don't trigger it if
you find it because I'm fairly certain
that when you do that it triggers the
craziest [ __ ] part of this whole
level I found 705 not this one just said
take the DNA core sample it didn't know
did it give you like a prompts yeah it's
like where was that it's it's right back
here under the right at the stairs just
you 9:49 such a memory here is it okay
on your prompt don't I think this might
trigger a crazy-ass sprint for our
[ __ ] lives thing okay I'm not a
hundred percent sure though another door
down here I don't know if it's an escape
or a pillow should we clear this room oh
yeah we take video we should get our
obably our roots out yeah try and do
this door over here yeah I wanna be
button man you guys you guys do the hard
okay I still have yet to stealth pop
something so I want it I want it what's
going on in here
okay or about nothing you usually hear
them immediately when you open another
door lights off lights off
Oh shimmy shimmy I heard it oh no it
this is this is where we came in from
we're good yeah this is a loop okay so
we have an escape room okay we have a
room we all can we look at the map for a
minute yeah look yeah so we're like here
yeah I think we need to go here here
here here here I think we need to go
back to this main area well there's a
door right here too let's be okay
triggered that you're afraid of is it a
thing we wrote summer forward
it's a horde but we don't want to defend
it here we have to get to the extract
right so we remembering the extract it's
like over here or something I so should
we set up our sentries back here
somewhere and then just run for it and
hold off your we extract
I think the choke point we want is this
okay I think we want to get back here
seafoam this and sentry added okay
there's no door we can hold and a lot of
these doors are [ __ ]
all right here's here's a crazy thought
what if we have a runner everyone else
sets up one person runs the sample back
okay quart or two yeah one or two
like the sentry guy sure oh I'm a
century guy well I can go set up and
then go run that's fine
yeah we should have a foam in a century
because I feel like I know the map
decently well okay oh we're like we're
left okay all right right team we're
gonna go set up I'm pretty sure this is
gonna be our choke okay okay this is
good tactics I like I'm gonna just turn
it like this way direction somebody
brought a good of a point what if it me
needs all of us to stand here to started
that is a fair concern also another
concern is if you guys are running with
enemies our turrets might let you all up
okay how about you just set up everyone
comes back we all run together yeah all
right
okay friends we probably shouldn't use
glow sticks to light our path back okay
Bob your point man all right I'm trigger
nice [ __ ] ready yep let's do it all
right yeah we got to be here good call
good call good call good call good call
yeah do we have to do circles and [ __ ]
then I hope not
nope we just got to turn to the point of
entrance in zone 49 okay it's time to go
yep okay no no you're good you're good
yep you're good they're very fast Oh God
okay just go dodge dodge Wow get behind
the turrets and seafoam get behind the
certs and seafoam yeah all right they're
coming in sea foaming and okay one more
seafoam all right Oh baby oh they're
coming whoever's in front of me stay
crouched for God's sakes
oh sorry okay you need like commissar in
military tactics for this ship yeah you
do
oh my god I'm running low on ammo it's
okay I got plenty damn and that up
literally the intro level it's worse it
gets so much worse that I cannot even
explain why is Wade's the only one with
stable mental status that's so fun oh
that's so fun oh good good great
[Music]